so you listened to the um to the
governor's speech earlier tonight and
with so many members of your vegas
chamber
was there a couple of takeaways that
left you with a little bit of hope or
promise
well absolutely there were several
promising takeaways the vegas chamber
applauds governor sislek on his very
pro-business approach
this was a very future focused agenda
there's a lot that the that the governor
did propose in his plan but we are
really extremely pleased
to see that governor sislek is not
proposing raising taxes on employers and
small businesses so
that's a very promising uh signal from
the governor we also appreciate that
he's recognizing that the number one
priority of our state
is restarting the economy and creating
jobs
he he did touch on on creating jobs and
one thing that
that was tough to hear was just the
amount of businesses
that will permanently close um was that
sort of a startling
i mean you know that you're on the front
line but was that that was kind of a
tough one to be
reminded of it is so startling to hear
the governor talk about the number of
small businesses that have
that have closed because small
businesses are the fabric of our
community and our economy
you know in nevada we have a lot we're
very fortunate to have a lot of great
um large-sized businesses but the
smallest
mom and pops are the ones who make up
the fabric of our economy
and so an enormous win for the small
businesses tonight
was the governor's announcement of
another 50 million dollars more
in pets grants as well as the
establishment of a small business
advocacy center
and a nevada job force so we were
extremely happy about that at the
biggest chamber
um so walk me through what a pet grant
is so i can explain that to our viewers
yes um and if i may
off the top of my head it is the
pandemic emergency
technical support grant and that's a
grant
that a lot of small businesses can apply
for
you can be a non-profit even chambers
can apply
so it's a very broad grant that really
will help a lot of businesses and
non-profits in our community
what is the the one thing that members
of your chamber
have been telling you over this past
year that maybe we didn't hear tonight
from the governor
that we didn't hear tonight i think you
know there's a lot that they've been
telling us just that they need more
financial assistance that's the main
thing the other biggest thing that
actually was the theme of the governor
tonight was talking about workforce
training
you know a lot of the members of the
vegas chamber say that the talent pool
is is very shallow and so that that can
sound kind of funny but
we were so happy to hear that one of the
governor's themes was
workforce training re-skilling and
upskilling
our members of our employment force and
that is just essential to getting people
back to work
you know nevada state college and the
college of southern nevada are important
to workforce training
especially for those in demand jobs like
healthcare
and so supporting these higher education
schools like
the unlv school of medicine and the
engineering school
those are much needed investments into
into helping people connect
with good paying jobs and sustainable
careers
um anything else you know i think he
also touched on just diversifying we are
so and we all know this right we're all
so
dependent on one industry but it's that
workforce training that will help us
diversify and will help us
deepen that talent pool right it is
absolutely the
the reskilling and upskilling of our
workforce workforce but you know the
other thing that we were really excited
about
is the governor asking for private
sector help in applying for more
federal grant dollars the vegas chamber
has worked closely over the years with
the brookings institute
the southern nevada forum and
assemblywoman danielle monroe moreno who
he also mentioned tonight
and so we commend the governor for
recognizing this dire need for these
federal grant dollars
and because nevada received some of the
least amount of federal grant dollars of
any state in the entire country simply
because we
don't apply for these dollars so by
applying for the federal grant dollars
we can bring
millions and millions of dollars in
funding to nevada that can be used to
tackle challenges like
public health education and human
services
any idea of how far away we might be
from that are these things that might
happen in q1
q2 you know i think they are definitely
we can certainly get these things
launched in in first quarter
and second quarter uh and and i know
that it's a priority of a lot of the
legislators i've spoken with and not
the least of which would be the governor
can businesses hold on though can they
hold on till this summer
well we hope so you know businesses we
are on the front lines of helping our
businesses and i think a lot of these
grants are going to go a long way
uh toward helping them hang on they're
trying so hard and we're just so proud
and honored to be working with our small
businesses
across the entire state of nevada
because they are
they're working so hard to stay in
business because they know how important
they are to our
economy